brought to you by msi computers msi
number one in gaming find out more at us
msi com starbucks for wii u was given a
release window and we got a sneak peek
at some gameplay my name is Jess
McDonald and here's a GS news update the
game will be called Star Fox zero and
it's being co-developed with platinum
games according to Nintendo visionary
Shigeru Miyamoto 0 doesn't necessarily
indicate that the new starfox game is a
prequel a remake or a sequel rather
Miyamoto chose the title 0 because he
appreciates the Chinese script 40 which
can be seen on the right hand side of
the games logo Star Fox zero looks very
similar to previous games in the series
particularly starfox 64 but Nintendo has
introduced a number of features for the
game including new vehicles and unique
gamepad controls so take advantage of
the second screen and motion sensing
gyroscope Star Fox zero should be out
holiday season of this year let me know
down in the comments if you're keen to
play starfox and for all the latest news
and trailers be sure to stay tuned
against both